I have a motto higher fast fire faster
promote fastest and yet I'll be honest
here and very vulnerable I struggle to
play that course because for me
personally the emotion of hurting
someone trumps the financial impact of
it and where I was able to mature into
later in my life was understanding the
ramifications it was having on everyone
else you know at the time I was in my
early 20s building my father's business
and really even into my late 30s I
really struggled with it and even today
my last book I called 12 and a half and
it talked about these traits that
mattered and I spoke about the half
Candor it was a struggle for me it's why
it was only a half I still needed to get
to a full I really do think a lot of
people struggle with the emotional
baggage of hurting someone